Rob Congrats on the podcast it's doing
great thank you
it's really exciting and and for those
of you don't know I do it with in
conjunction with Conan's company and I'm
just once again sucking off your
intellectual property Conan I listen you
know I'm just drafting behind you as
I've done my entire career your entire
career going back to the mid 80s was
drafting off of my success even though I
was a complete unknown and a failure at
the time I don't know how you did that
but I somehow knew that our paths would
cross in the podcast world that we would
we would be the dirt we're the darlings
in the podcast world this week I mean
this way well you know we'll be that for
this week and then we have to find a new
medium next week
next week that's right yes I'm going to
go into the interpretive dance touring
business next week you'd be good and I
think you'd be I think I've seen you do
interpreting interpretive dance
that's called me walking that's just
what I look like when I walk I you know
there's a couple things to talk about
first of all where we're going through
this long long quarantine and I am
falling apart day by day my hair is the
longest it's ever been that the
pompadour has collapsed collapsed I look
like I'm having a nervous breakdown you
look better than ever and it enrages me
what are you doing well I don't know if
you noticed but I have sorted Backstreet
Boys highlights my hair right now I
didn't know it yet that's it I was so
bored that I was gonna go for the Robert
De Niro mohawk and taxi driver and I got
talked out of it good and I was like
well then I want to just put really
crazy highlights like like I'm a member
of NSYNC and so it's not like I I'm
totally keeping up with my you know
heritage here I'm I'm slipping look look
what's become of me well first of all it
looks it looks fantastic no thank you
you look good as always I know that your
wife is a makeup specialist artist yes
she is so she probably gives you a
little help
and I'm assuming that you um consumed
some sort of devil blood at night
there's something you do that you're not
telling anybody you have a frozen give
one of those chambers that freezes your
body and face do you have one of those
Oh like a cyber genetic like the kind of
thing that Walt Disney is supposedly
buried in don't act like you don't have
one it's you know you don't know what
you're talking about yeah yeah yeah I
don't know what you're talking about
Conan I do I would never have anything
like that ever
okay all right okay take it easy it's
too close by the way I would do that in
two seconds if there was such a thing I
would sleep in it and I would I would be
so down to clown with that I would what
are you drinking there is that some sort
of special juice I need to know about
this is this is that what did you say it
was the blood of Devils a special juice
what is that yeah is that like is that
some I know you're on you have you once
told me that you keep little
moisturizers that you yourself make in
your pocket and you sometimes moisturize
I do iin ulcers I am my own skincare
line profile cobalt and I do have one
our biggest seller is an under-eye
rollerball that helps you with aging and
fine lines and wrinkles and like if I
come into a meeting and I want a little
like let's pull it out a bit a bit and
no one's the wiser I pitched my own line
of face care products for men a few
years ago and the tagline was so you can
look like Conan I lost everything I lost
I lost everything I lost the house lost
the beach house everything gone
apparently no one wants to look like
Conan
well you I can tease now for the
audience that you are on the podcast
coming up and I think your week after
next and you talked about how when you
walk on the beach that you look like
Rose Kennedy at the end
yeah it's true yeah when she when she
was a hundred and seven and they would
take her to the beach and they would
just drape her in blankets and hats she
looked like a pile of laundry that was
tumbling day and that's it
I think that's what I think of you you
want to think of you just in the
neighborhood at your little beach house
you your clam shack you like to escape
to I'll know it's you if it looks
literally if it looks like laundry and
blankets who I am gonna be no there's
Conan I'll go say aye